[Music]
one of the really interesting
corollaries that's part of many of these
stories the corollaries of focus and
these are the stories of ernest
shackleton the explorer the US President
Abraham Lincoln famous african-american
abolitionist Frederick Douglass a very
important resistor to Hitler in Nazi
Germany Dietrich Bonhoeffer and the
environmental activist Rachel Carson is
that each of them discover that focus is
not only a way of bringing out their
best possibilities their bet their
greatest power as leaders it's also a
way of conceding what isn't important
and giving away all of that stuff so let
me give you a really interesting example
in the early 1850s Lincoln gives a law
lecture to a bunch of aspiring lawyers
and he says look I learned the hard way
that if I could swing a jury to my side
on the one or two or three critical
issues that really mattered to the case
I could simply give away everything else
to my opponent I could give away this
point then I could give away this point
then I could give away this point and
then I could give away this point
because I only needed to hold on to
those one two or three issues and by
doing so I could one disarmed the
opposition to keep the jury very focused
on where they needed to be focused and
three claimed all that I needed and
nothing more for a judicial victory and
I think that is just a great lesson writ
large for our moment we have so many
leaders right now and so many of us want
at some emotional level to have all the
victories to get all the goodies to be
perfect on every front and each of these
people learn that the real power like
that real power for leaders lies in
giving away the unimportant stuff in
recognizing what's a small or
unimportant victory and joyfully handing
to someone else including one of one's
opponent and that in the doing of that
now the only does one hold on to what
really matters
one masters oneself enough not
not to need to have victory on every
single front all the time and there is
great power and great self-knowledge in
the doing of that that create on the
outside a kind of confidence that people
are very much attracted to and motivated
by one of the things that each of these
people learn and I think is particularly
relevant today is the importance of
focusing on one or two or even three but
it's never more than three it's one or
two maybe three never more things at a
time why is it so important that leaders
today as in these stories learn the
emotional discipline learn the the
fearsome ineluctable logic of only
focusing on a few things it's so
important because first there are a
number of things everyday that only a
leader can do every time we say no to
those four three critical things one two
or three and say yes to the Twitter
announcement that just dung on our phone
say yes to the email notification that
get just came through we have 12
unanswered emails in the last 10 minutes
say yes to the person the doubting
Thomas in our office who wants to tell
you why things are wrong and can never
be right every time we say yes to all
those things we're saying no the the
things that only we as leaders in our
respective paths can do and so we were
saying no to moving the mission forward
even if it's just a few inches in this
moment and that is really important
right now when in so many ways Rome is
burning around us and leaders of all
kinds of walks of life of all kinds of
stripes and sizes have so many things
coming at them that are not critical so
the first reason is a leader can only do
certain things and a leader owes it to
himself or herself his mission his
followers though the larger global
village to keep on focusing on those
things that's the first reason the
second reason it's really critical is if
we don't work all by ourselves we have
to be able to
delegate to others the active delegation
is as an act of empowerment it's an act
of trust it's an act of sharing and I
see so many leaders myself included I'm
not sure I'm a leader but I'm certainly
a coach and the teacher and a writer I
see myself you know kind of trying to
control everything all at once from you
know the state of my laundry - which is
a really useful procrastination device
when you're writing a book as long as I
did - oh my god I better reorder my
Inbox - you know what about what's
happening on Twitter right now I'm doing
all those things and I'm not finishing
the things I need to finish in a
leadership coaching post I'm writing for
people that are depending on me to get
this out as a way of motivating them or
guiding them or helping them
I worry a great deal about about not
only leaders focusing on those one or
two things because only they can do them
but the fact that I'm I have a small
team of people around me who are want to
and are paid to take on these
responsibilities and the more I try and
control the more I effectively often
unconsciously unintentionally take away
their roles their responsibilities and
their sense of investment in the larger
mission so the second reason this is so
critical is that other people are part
of the story part of the team part of
the mission they need to feel part of
that and they need to do the work they
can do so that the leader can do what he
or she must do in the focus in the
narrowing down our attention to the
three critical things we are also giving
ourselves permission to sink deeply into
ourselves to consider the importance of
what we're doing and the people affected
by it and to really reflect on how we
can do that with nuance and integrity
and wisdom and decency and a sense of
being right for ourselves and those
aspects are not possible when we are
living you know in seventeen time zones
at once with 30 file folders if you will
open on our mental desktop at all times
we've got to learn to identify the one
or two or three things
and give the rest away and rediscover
our own leadership power in the process
of doing that
[Music]